who created your parents where do your
parents come from their parents and
where do they come from their parents
but you can't have an infinite
regression meaning it has to get back to
some point right and that point would be
God
all right what are your names
Ty and Emma all right Ava nice to meet
you guys my name is Rami if I were to
ask you guys what's your purpose in life
what's your objective in life how would
you answer that question I want to make
a difference like I want to be able to
impact people's lives do you know what I
mean I don't want to just live for me I
want to live to make other people happy
it's very Noble okay I like that answer
how about you I'm gonna go with like
live love laugh live love love okay
[Applause]
all right all right now for where to ask
you where did you guys get these
objectives these purposes from I think
it was probably just the way I was
raised I have a younger brother who's
disabled and he has like a rare form of
epilepsy if you know what that is so
I've just always had at the back of my
Minds like never to take life for
granted and to always help other people
around you
it's very beautiful that's very
beautiful and you you see me I've got it
from a book right I did it in fact he
did get it from a book okay if someone
came to you and they said well you got
your purpose from your family and what
you observed from your family you got
your purpose from a book right which
actually I don't think is a bad thing
and I'll touch on that in a second
you'll see why towards the end but what
if I said that's actually not your
purpose or that's a part of your purpose
but there's a greater overall purpose
that that encap that encapsulates what
you said and you as well there's a
greater overall purpose that actually
encapsulates what you just said what do
you guys think that would be
foreign
it's actually kind of funny nowadays
that people would be shocked at the
answer I'd be like oh that's cliche but
dude you know making people happy and so
on and so forth did that create you and
put you on this Earth no no parents
parents so parents that's a part of it
for sure who created your parents where
do your parents come from their parents
and where do they come from their
parents but you can't have an infinite
regression meaning it has to get back to
some point right and that point would be
God God 100 I'm not a Christian
Missionary by any chance I hope you guys
know that I'm a Muslim missionary God
put us on this Earth so yes make people
happy to make them laugh to spread good
and join good and forbid evil and to
make people's lives better and easier
100 that's a part of it so that's why I
said there's an overall purpose that we
have why we're put on this Earth but if
we don't have that intention in mind
then if you think about it we're
actually missing our purpose would you
guys say you worship living loving and
laughing and you worship helping people
no no you don't worship it how about you
no you don't worship it right but if you
worship God then by default you would be
doing these nice beautiful things and
helping people making their lives better
and you know the reason I say that it
kind of doesn't work with you because
you have a very noble cause most people
say you know I'm not saying that you're
you're worse or anything don't don't
don't get that don't get the wrong idea
most people say and I just spoke to
three young men they're like oh you know
make money live comfortably so on and so
forth these things are actually taught
to us that's not our purpose
they're actually taught to us and we
assign them to ourselves so what we do
is we need to change the source our
purpose actually comes from the one who
made us and he created us give us a bro
just close your eyes for a second all
right just close your eyes for a second
I'm not gonna do anything I promise
imagine that was all you could see or
that you couldn't see anything we didn't
pay for our site but yet it's something
so beautiful now open your eyes and see
all the colors
how beautiful is that
we got our site for free and God puts us
on his Earth and he says just worship me
all right no if you don't mind holding
this for a second my friend course
you're talking to I don't mind so I just
want to open this verse because it's
actually inspired my question now I've
been asking people today
and it says this this is the Quran by
the way right from God delivered through
the prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
we believe in the prophet Muhammad Jesus
Noah Abraham all of these you know
people as prophets and messengers of God
and this is what the Quran says
after this brief Interruption it says
have you seen those people who have
taken their own desires as their God
meaning that whatever you desire in a
life to have Fame and force your money
you make that your God meaning that you
dedicate your life to this thing when in
actuality we should dedicate our life to
God
so what I want to do for you too and by
the way are you guys related you guys
dating or dating so I'll give this to
both of you
as a gift and I hope that yeah I take it
it's all yours my man it's all yours I
need some popcorn though brother I'm
gonna just need a little bit I'm a feed
for popcorn they call me the Halal Drake
but I Love Popcorn
that's uh that's our lovely brother SQ
over there so I wanted to give it to you
guys as a gift so hopefully you can read
it find some insight and to find better
insight into your greater purpose in
life of course it's my pleasure Ty and
Ava right all right it's been a pleasure
guys have a great night of course
yeah have a good night
wow another another one another one
mashallah seriously man seriously great
job Rami honestly you guys watching at
home you can do this as well don't think
that we're some special talented people
whatever no Allah is using you as well
two for spreading this Dean so don't
think that there's some exclusive
Monopoly for US versus you no everyone
could do this everyone could do this
brother Romney's showing you right now
we are just coming up and pulling up on
people and you guys are going to do this
as well too and I want you guys to send
us videos of you giving dawa right take
out your phones record and just use it
just figure it out send it so we're
gonna feature on our Channel as well too
street that way you know what it is
we're taking over Insha'Allah may Allah
bless you all a message go give dawa go
give Dao you already know what it is
[Music]
how would your objectives here or the
way you view them not be considered
worship when you're liked you would even
argue or could say revolves around this
thing
is not to make money and to live super
comfortably while other people are
suffering and so on and so forth because
they couldn't make it and you could what
if I said that's not your purpose what
if you had a greater purpose in life and
I could tell you what that was would you
then go and seek that purpose gotta hear
this purpose oh yeah I gotta hear
sir sir sir sir uh just really quick
what do you believe happens to you after
you die
phenomenal phenomenal
[Music]